survival instinct is one thing the
Earth's reproduced certainly exists as
well and I think it's part of this part
of the innate human nature but again
it's something that can be overstated a
lot of people would say why it's crazy
that we would ever use birth control you
know the idea if you'd last people 200
years ago whether they would actually
submit to the concept of limiting their
appropriation in order to control
population or whatever it was that crazy
idea but sure enough when infants stops
dying very often you know we all did it
and it's only because our expensive we
didn t a draconian laws or anything like
that so if we look at this Saturday we
see the same sort of thing we seen
falling fertility rates in pretty much
all of the relic world and even the
wider world like China's below
replacement level already India is
plummeting and they haven't had a once
our policy or anything they're nearly
down to a replacement level um more than
that even women who are having children
they're having them later as if that
delaying until they have to have
children because menopause and you know
problems with Down syndrome and so on
are coming along so I think that's
really good news it means that actually
are um you know our presumption that
there is this innate drive to have kids
quite often may not be so strong as we
may have been brought up to believe and
that actually if we were to eliminate
menopause and the you know the decline
of quality of the egg cells and
therefore the decline of the safety of
having kids then women were actually
pressing them in any way would continue
to lay there procreation even further so
it might actually not be correct in
thinking that would be a serious
overpopulation problem if we eliminated
ating
hey